[Music]
Final Fantasy 15 s 13th chapter has been
the source of numerous complaints
specifically with how it handles the
game's story thankfully publisher Square
Enix plans to address these issues next
month I'm Matt and this gamespot news
update needs no further patches the
chapter 13 update releases on March 28
after Final Fantasy 15 s launch chapter
13 became the subject of much discussion
as it shifted the game from its
sprawling open-world to a more linear
format while glossing over some of the
more important narrative threads without
explanation the update is joined by the
game's first piece of DLC episode
gladiolus which is an original story
that'll put players in control of Knox's
companion Gladio a price for the DLC has
not been confirmed Square Enix plans to
release another update on ferry 21st
this one expands ps4 prosupport
introduces limited time quests and
raises the level cap to 120 among other
things we'll keep you updated on all the
latest final fantasy news so for that
and more from the world of video games
stay tuned to gain spawns